[Music]
your TV wife Rachel Harris Rachel Harris
she was here just a few weeks ago and
she she spent half a segment talking
about your backside your butt your rear
end and she claimed that it was the best
male but that she had ever seen and you
yourself tweet constantly oh please yes
you do you sweet constantly about having
the best ass on prime time
is that not true is it true she started
it
Yeah right but you don't need to make up
the banner and run with it though there
was a national vote
I just national vote I don't I didn't go
to the polls
I don't remember lining up with everyone
else and voting on who has the best ass
curtain in everything I heard there was
a vote there was a national vote for
best butt on prime time and so I just
jumped on the bandwagon right so you won
you have the best but we even you even
post pictures like this well check out
this picture are you what are you doing
well giving birth on the sidewalk why
what man does that what I'm doing I have
a very tight right flexor the flexors oh
my god I see true I was loosening up my
flexor you were loosening up your flex
my story ons when you saw the paparazzi
moments the time to go yeah that out
oh yeah that's the stuff do you do a lot
of exercises back there is this
something you were born with no yeah oh
yeah yeah it's a little genetic and but
you know I'm not afraid of the deadlift
or the squat you know so you're trying
to enhance your your bottom yes you can
you know I know at some point it's gonna
fall so I might as well keep father time
at bay for surgery for that isn't there
can't you have your butt raised and sure
and yet what Andy yeah that's crap it
takes it up oh yeah have implants put in
I have no butt at all I have there's
nothing there it's a straight drop from
my shoulders sorry
so it's okay no one seems to care I
slide out of chairs because there's
nothing there it's not me but I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get stuff put back there
at some point yeah yeah what are you
fidgeting around for like you know but
you know unlike you though you know mine
is a rock-hard so even something as Tiny
as this causes extreme discomfort on one
of the cheeks not in between I'm one of
them
no one knew what what you were saying I
know that's I do there's many different
ways to take that all right you posted
this picture let's talk about what's
going on here what's what's going on
there just watching some football game
fellas got to be comfortable
I was I was gonna say job interview
Faraz yeah that was actually a scene
from Oz where help Renault is doing some
kind of Greek chorus monologue and you
know how you don't you can't really tell
what a guy's really like underneath it
all now used to say years ago you would
tell me that you would get propositioned
by guys that were big oz fans is that
still happening yeah you know wrong
place wrong time or right place right
time depending on how you want to do it
but yeah it's you know I like to hit the
gym and it's usually where that happens
when does it happen is it while you're
working out someone comes up in
propositions you what's what I know it's
mostly in the showers you know they they
lather a bit too long down in the nether
regions never speaking but just always
with this look
did you know what I said just with the
eyebrows yeah yeah what you speak shower
yeah well I'm just I'm just curious
that's surprising to me that men they
that's the that's the co I guess it's a
showering you're down that region I'm
real a the ring and shout I mean how
long can you spend down there it's the
that's the point it's the slow lather
and you're like everyone wants it clean
down there but let's come up for air
stop let's go get the hands where I can
see them that's right come on do you
ever tell him you know that's I go you
know cuz you know you know you're doing
your thing he's just you know washing
and you can feel the energy and you like
and your first thought is really really
do we have to well first of all you just
watching yourself are you doing some
kind of crazy squat in the shower well I
just did work out so I am a little tight
yeah yeah